Bitte schön.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ismail Yavash. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistant
Architekt, ich würde gerne wieder das Haftnahmegeschäft führen. Bitte fragen Sie mich nach etwas nicht verstehen.
Ich möchte Ihnen mit Ihnen Personal Daten stellen. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Schmet Klaudia.
Schmet ist die Nachname, Klaudia ist die Vorname.
Klaudia mit C, L, A, O, D, I, A.
Nicht mit K, mit C.
Schmet Klaudia, Herzschmidt Klaudia.
Frau Schmitt.
Frau?
Klaudia ist immer eine Vorname.
Frau Klaudia Schmitt, okay.
Frau Klaudia Schmitt.
Okay, Frau Schmitt, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 40 Jahre alt.
40 Jahre alt, okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
71.
Wie viel wiegt sie?
80 Kilo.
Okay, Frau Schmitt, was können Sie tun?
Okay, warum ich hier gekommen bin?
Natürlich das gute Frage. Wie können Sie mich auch helfen?
Ich würde sagen, ich habe so eine starken Überbauchschmerzen.
Seit gestern eigentlich, aber es ist nicht mehr anzuhalten.
Die Schmerzen an sich ist vermehrt.
Die ist gestern so plötzlich aufgetreten.
Und jetzt nimmt es zu, so zu sagen, an sich.
Mein Mann hat gesagt, ich muss jetzt in den Krankenhaus und daher.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie mich helfen können.
Wo können Sie die Schmerzen haben?
Genau, haben Sie die Schmerzen.
Es ist eher so eine Überbauchschmerz, wo die Magen,
unter die Magenbereich, kann ich nicht genau beschreiben.
Manchmal habe ich auch in den Rücken,
mit dem Ausstrahlung, in den Rücken.
Aber es ist in den Überbauchbereich.
In den Rückenbereich?
Ja, genau, auch mit dem Ausstrahlung.
Können Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Die Brüllen, die Rücken, die Schmerzen,
die Schmerzen oder die Krampferdike?
Das ist eher guter Formiggeschmerzen.
Ein guter Formiggeschmerz, als was hier so ein Fasster auf dem Bauchdruck zu sein.
Vor Überbauchs.
Okay, guter Formiggeschmerz, ob er erreicht.
Wissen Sie, zu Hause habe ich viele Probleme mit meiner Bruder auch.
Er hat auch Depressionen und Medikamente und trinkt auch viel.
Ich versuche, mit ihm zu trinken, aber nicht so viel.
Aber er nervt mich auch ohne Ende.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie ich mit dem ganzen Problem zu Hause ist.
Ob sie auch eine Beratung oder eine Lösung für die Probleme,
die ich zu Hause habe, auch geben kann.
Okay.
Leber Sie mit Ihrer Bruder?
Ja, der ist fast bei uns zu Hause.
Er lebt nicht mit uns zusammen, aber er ist jeden Tag bei mir zu Hause.
Er kommt zu Hause und trinkt mit sich aus dem Alkohol und Bier noch dazu.
Er raucht auch viel.
Daher rauch ich auch passiv mit ihm.
Manchmal rauche ich auch aktiv.
Wie streiten wir uns gegenseitig?
Mein Mann ist auch am Ende, der kann es nicht mehr vertragen.
Weiß ich nicht genau.
Sie haben viele Probleme mit Ihrem Bruder.
Okay, wie stark sind Sie auf einer Skate,
auf einer wie zehn, einer der leichtesten,
die es schon gibt?
Ja, da ist es zwischen sieben bis neun,
weil ich noch zu Hause eine Medikamente angenommen habe.
Er hat mich etwas geholfen.
Aber es ist trotzdem nicht mehr anzuhalten.
Ich bitte Sie, dass Sie mich auch etwas geben können.
Wie weißt du, dass Sie die Medikamente nehmen?
Ich habe es zu Hause versucht mit Nouvellevine,
was ich noch vorhanden hatte, einzunehmen.
Damit ging es etwas besser.
Ich konnte es bis heute Morgen durchhalten.
Aber es scheint nicht ausreichend, dass es noch mehr Brucher gibt.
Okay.
Sie haben diese Schmerzen gestern plötzlich aufgetreten.
Gibt es etwas, das dich meistens verstarke oder lehnt?
Vielleicht nach dem Fettikeessen oder mit Bewegung?
Eigentlich hat nichts zu tun.
Als ich gestern plötzlich aufgetreten,
da gibt es keine Medikamente oder keine Auslöse,
wie ich jetzt beurteile.
Ich habe es gestern aufgetreten.
Ich konnte es auch nicht herausfinden.
Woher kommt denn Beschwärten?
Ich habe es bis heute Morgen nicht mehr verstanden.
Wie sieht es mit dem Stuhlgang aus?
Seit gestern habe ich auch Verstoffungen.
Ich habe es gestern aufgetreten.
Dann habe ich habe verstoffen.
Ich war so gewohnt, dass ich es zwei, dreimal pro Tag auf der Toilette gehe.
Aber seit gestern konnte ich auch nicht mehr.
Wie ist der Rebizit?
Meine Appetit ist eigentlich auch nicht so viel.
Es war gut.
Ja, natürlich durch das Stress, das ich zu Hause habe.
Das kann ich auch nicht genau sagen,
wie es sein soll.
nicht so ganz okay. Haben Sie auch letzter Zeit aufgenommen oder so genommen? Ja, so ein Abgenommen
schon, so drei Kilo würde ich sagen, das ist auch durch die Stress, dass ich zu Hause habe. Drei Kilo?
Ja, abgenommen, drei Kilo.
Gehen Sie trotz okay. Okay, Frau Schmidt, jetzt wir kommen, allgemein fragen,
wie ist das mit dem Wasser lassen, ist das in Ordnung? Ja, aber ich kann kein Problem.
Haben Sie Alborösschen? Ich habe seit gestern ja drei, vier Mal erbrochen auch.
Einmal? Einmal? Drei, vier Mal.
Okay, genau.
Achtschikassens dann, Achtschikassens, ja.
Okay. Haben Sie Schüttachproff, Fieber oder Schweißhaushilfbrücke?
Bevor ich das beantwortet, habe ich gesagt, kann ich meine Mann anrufen, dass ich mal ihm sage, dass ich im Krankenhaus bin,
dass er sich nicht sorge macht, wo ich bin. Darf ich meine Mann anrufen?
Vielleicht.
Haben Sie eine Telefon für mich, weil ich keine Handi dabei habe. Hallo?
Ja.
Ja, ich höre Ihnen. Ja.
Bitte, können Sie bitte noch mal wiederholen?
Ja, gesagt, darf ich meine Mann mal anrufen, dass ich ihm sage, dass ich im Krankenhaus bin,
nicht, dass er sich sorge macht, er weiß nicht genau, wo ich bin.
Ich habe ihm ja auch nichts gesagt, ich bin einfach rausgekommen und direkt ins Krankenhaus gefahren.
Er weiß nicht genau, wo ich bin. Haben Sie eine Telefon, wo ich dann mal ihm anrufen kann?
Ja, ich schuldige mich, ich nicht, ich nicht, was ich da in der Tür muss.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich bin, ich rede langsam mehr.
Ich bin einfach direkt nach Krankenhaus gefahren, ohne dass ich meine Mann zu informieren,
dass ich nach Krankenhaus fahre.
Ja, und daher, der weiß auch nicht genau, wo ich bin, jetzt sagt er.
Ob Sie eine Telefon haben, wo ich damit einmal anrufen kann, dass Sie ihm sagen, dass ich ...
Ja, okay, Sie können anrufen, Ihre Mann, ja.
Okay, sehr gut, ja, okay.
Okay.
Wenn ich schnell bin, sagen Sie mir Bescheid, dass ich langsam rede.
Das ist auch nicht schlimm.
Nein, nein, alles gut, danke schon.
Fraschimit, gibt es Probleme mit Ihren Monatsprodukten?
Mit dem Periode, meinen Sie?
Ja, Periode, ja.
Ja, habe ich gar kein Problem damit.
Okay, haben Sie viel was?
Leichtes und warm gefühlt, ich habe es nicht gemissen.
Okay, haben Sie Schutterfrost oder Schweißerspüchel?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Okay.
Und jetzt, wir kommen in Ihren Krankengeschichte, gibt es wichtige Erkrankungen mit Ihnen,
vielleicht Blutdoktor, oder Suckerkrankheiten, Erskrankungen oder andere?
Ob ich unter einer Erkrankung leider mein sinne Krone schere Erkrankung?
Ja, kur anerischer Erkrankung.
Nein, ich bin 40 Jahre alt, was soll ich haben?
Ich bin noch jung.
Haben Sie einen Unfall gehabt?
Zum Unfall habe ich auch nie gehabt, nee.
Bleiben Sie in Krankenhaus vielleicht?
Ob ich in Krankenhaus geblieben war oder ob ich mal aufgenommen worden war,
oder das meinst du, oder?
Ja, ja.
Ob ich mal schon nicht, dass sie nicht aufgenommen worden war.
Nee, ich war nie in Krankenhaus auch.
Sind Sie opryt worden?
Habe ich gesagt, nee, weil ich auch keine Opintern nicht gehabt habe.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente, eine Regelmessage oder Beide?
Ja, ab und zu kennen Sie schon bei Frauen in der Rahmenperiode.
Manchmal hat man so eine starke Schmerzen,
muss man ab und zu das einnehmen, aber das ist auch normal, das muss man sagen.
Das ist nicht bekannt, das mal über Profen einzunehmen.
Das ist auch normal, oder?
Normalerweise, ja.
Das ist normal für Sie.
Haben Sie Allergien gegen bestimmte Medikamente oder Plansen?
Allergien sind bekannte Allergien, ob ich habe.
Nee, das ist mir nicht bekannt, ich habe keine bekannte Allergien.
Okay.
Gibt es Unwerklichkeiten gegen Lebensmittel, Galaktos, Frukto, Galaktos?
Also Lebensmittelunfallerzüglichkeiten.
Ich habe keine Lebensmittelunverträglichkeiten,
das ist mir auch nichts bekannt, außer seit gestern natürlich
kann ich nichts mehr vertragen.
Auch weil ich ständig durch die Schmerzen,
ab und zu beschweren, dass ich aktuell habe,
aber ich will gar nichts essen und trinken.
Da ist mir immer danach schnell schlecht und muss ich erbrechen,
muss ich mich übergeben.
Okay.
Jetzt frage ich mit, willkommen in einer Familiengeschichte.
Gibt es mit jeder Familien anhörige wichtige Erkrankungen
oder krönliche Erkrankungen?
Ja, eigentlich.
Vater, Mutter.
Ja, die sind kein gesund, aber mein Bruder,
der belastete ganze Familie.
Der ist eine große Sorge für uns und große Probleme.
Und weißt du nicht genau, wie wir damit umgehen sollen.
Okay. Vater, Mutter ist gesund.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, habe ich keine.
Okay.
Jetzt willkommen in einer Johannheit.
Rachen Sie?
Nein.
Seit ich mit meinen Brudern zu Hause immer uns treffen,
habe ich auch angefangen zu rauchen.
Das ist seit fünf Jahren, muss ich sagen, jeden Tag so,
fünf, sechs Sekret und auch mit ihm zusammen,
der raucht auch fast 20 pro Tag.
Das heißt, ich rauche auch mit ihm zusammen.
Wir sitzen zusammen und wir streiten, wir leben fast zusammen.
Und ich habe mit meinen Brudern,
sie haben fünf Jahre 20 Sekreteprotakt,
genau, richtig?
Nicht mit meinem Bruder,
ich rauche seit fünf Jahren,
zwischen fünf bis sechs Sekretten,
aber als ich gesagt habe,
meine Bruder braucht fast 20 Sekreteprotakt.
Und der ist der ganze Tag zu Hause bei mir, zu Hause.
Ja, okay.
Und ich rauche auch Parallel mit ihm, oder?
Ja, ja.
Weiß ich nicht genau, das ist ein Siebester.
Ja, Passivrahus.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, jetzt schon.
Nicht viel, da war.
Wie oft trinken Sie und wie Bier oder Wein welcher Alkohol trinken Sie?
Ich trink so ein Air-Bier mit meinem Bruder,
so drei bis vier pro Tag.
Wie viel? Erschöntegeme?
Drei, vier.
Drei, vier, okay.
Pro Tag.
Ja.
Nehmen Sie irgendwer, der es schon ist?
Ne, habe ich nie genommen.
Gott sei Dank.
Sie sind verarretet.
Sie leben mit ihrem Bruder in Reichelsimmer.
Und Sie haben kein Kinder.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Putzfrau.
Bitte?
Putzfrau.
Putzfrau, einfach kurz.
Ja, ja, ja, okay.
Okay, jetzt sind wir fertig, Frau Schmidt.
Möchten Sie etwas sagen oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich habe Sie gewitten, dass Sie mich etwas gegen Schmerzen zu geben.
Ich brauche noch jetzt dringend den Schmerzmitteln,
damit ich zur Ruhe kommen kann.
Ja, okay.
Frau Schmidt, Sie haben Baschmassen.
Sie haben die erste, wie Körperliche Untersuchung machen
und Blutfurschlabs abgenommen und Bauchrahmen.
Ihr habt es akustisch nicht verstanden.
Nach dem Kölb untersuchen, was machen Sie noch?
Blutfurschlabers abgenommen und Bauchrahmen.
Sie können auch so einfach Blut untersuchen.
Dann, wie solltet ihr nach dem kölb- und röntgenunterjahr im Bau
und nach dem alle Befunde vorlegen, ich komme Ihnen und ich spreche über Ihre Station.
Aber ein bisschen Sie müssen mit uns bleiben.
Ja, aber ich kann es nicht anhalten.
Sie haben so eine starke Schmerz, Sie müssen so lange warten.
Ja, Sie müssen mich was geben.
Vielleicht gebe ich Ihnen eine Medikamente.
Genau, das spricht mir.
Ich gebe Ihnen eine Telefon-Siegerrufe an Ihre Mann.
Das ist sehr nett, danke schön.
Das haben wir den Probleme gelöst.
Okay, haben wir was vergessen anhand der Nämnese?
Aber Sie haben es toll gemacht, muss ich sagen.
Wie viel Jahre, wie lange?
Ungefähr 2-3 Jahre.
Gute Frage.
Haben Sie Gasverbung in der Harte oder in Albenbemerk?
Ne, habe ich nicht gepennt.
Auch gute Frage.
Und waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Ne, weiß ich auch nicht.
Impe Status, müssen Sie auch fragen.
Heute ist der Standard.
Ich bin dreimal geimpft.
Okay, was noch?
Ansonsten...
Haben Sie Schlafprobleme seit gestern?
Ja, weil ich da Schmerzen habe.
Noch?
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie etwas früher schon einmal hätten.
Noch mal, ich habe es nicht genau verstanden.
Ich habe es richtig gehört.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie so etwas früher schon einmal hätten.
Okay, ob Sie den gleichen Symptom einmal hatte.
Ich habe das gleiche Beschwerden nie gehabt.
Als ich gesagt habe, das ist das erste Mal, dass ich so etwas habe.
Noch?
Ich glaube, das Manager hat das richtig alles gut analysiert.
Es hat ein paar Kleinigkeiten, aber es hat toll gemacht.
Obwohl ich versucht, ihm so etwas verwirrende und durcheinander zu bringen,
aber ich habe es nicht geschafft.
Okay, dann, weiter.
Gestern, wie viel haben Sie getrunken?
Wie viel habe ich gestern getrunken?
Ich stelle jeden Tag, als Sie gesagt haben, 3 bis 4, trinke ich nicht viel.
Wie immer, das war nicht, dass ich gestern noch mehr getrunken habe.
Was haben Sie gestern gegessen?
Gestern habe ich fast gar nichts gegessen.
Weil ich gestern die Probleme habe und ich habe durch die Schmerzen kein Appetit mehr gehabt.
Auch Appetit habe ich nicht gegessen.
Ich habe mich für die Probleme getrunken.
Ja, die Probleme sind gestern Morgen.
Okay.
Ich habe ein bisschen Frühstück, um 6 Uhr einen Kaffee getrunken.
Dann habe ich ein Brot mit Butter drauf geschmiert und gegessen.
Das war nicht so viel eigentlich.
Ich habe am meisten vernünftige Frühstück. Gestern war das nicht der Fall.
Okay, dann, machen wir jetzt als Hassgespräch.
Ja.
Okay.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Schönen guten Tag.
Wir sind eine Patientin auf Genomen, auf einer Restation.
Wir haben.
Haben Sie Zeit?
Ja, ich habe Zeit für Sie.
Okay.
Frau Schmidt.
40 Jahre Patientin.
Gestern Morgen.
Plötzlich auf getretener Schmerzen.
Im Obermittelbau auf unserer Restation 4.
Okay.
Oberbau nicht mittel, aber ist das okay?
Oberbau.
Weiteren, bestätten Sie in den Rücken seit Bereits auf die Schmerzen,
in den Rücken im Bereich aufstrahlen würden.
Das ist ein bisschen komplizierter Satz.
Sie können es ein bisschen vereinfachen.
Die stellt sich mit stark Oberbauchschmerzen vor, haben Sie gesagt.
Die schmerzende Strahlen in den Rücken einfach.
Können Sie auch so einfach sagen.
Versuchen nicht, den Satz zu kompliziert zu bauen,
dann haben Sie selbst Probleme.
Daher versuchen Sie einfach Satz zu bauen.
Okay.
Also mit der bestrahlenden Schmerz in den Rücken.
So können Sie auch sagen.
Mit den bestrahlenden Schmerz in den Rücken.
Okay.
Die Schmerzinterstate liegt bei 7 bis 9 sehr starker Schmerzen.
Die Beschwerden sind von Konstipation und Emesis begleitet.
Die Schmerzen sind von gestern 3 oder 4 Mal erbrochen.
Gestern waren 2 oder 3 Mal in der Tuolete gegangen.
Aber nicht Tuolete machen.
Soll ich denn hier korrigieren, S Manager?
Sie versuchen einfach so ein kompliziert Satz zu bauen.
Versuchen Sie sich nicht, weil dann können Sie sich selbst nicht verfolgen, was Sie sagen.
Einfach wenn Sie sagen, dass Sian hat Obstepation zum Beispiel.
Seit gestern hat Obstepation.
Okay, Obstepation.
Wenn Sie nicht unbedingt sagen, dass der auf Tuolete gegangen war und hat das nicht geklappt,
dann müssen Sie nicht fest.
Das macht dann die Probleme noch mehr als an sich, was es ist.
Und als Sie gesagt, versuchen Sie ein Fachbegriff einfach zu benutzen.
Sian hat seit gestern Obstepation.
Die Schmerz in den Skalas liegt zwischen 7 bis 9.
Noch weiter bitte.
Die Schmerz, die Schmerzen, guter Formel, die Schmerzen.
Letzter Zeit ging es in den Stress in den Haus 3 kg abgenommen.
Seit wie lange hat die 3 kg abgenommen?
Einige Monate.
Einige Monate gegen Stress.
Sie haben ein Bruder und ihre Brüder,
haben Depressionen und trinken viel Alkohol, Bier
und viele Probleme, so haben sie mit ihrem Mann und
nicht ihre Brüder erhalten.
So haben sie viele Probleme,
die Schmerzprobleme mit ihrem Bruder.
Und Monatsbrüten ist normal.
Die Fragen nach Fiebers, Schutterfröss
oder Schweißausbrüten verneint.
Sie haben 3 Mal gegen Corona geimpft.
Sie haben keine wichtige chronische Erkrankungen.
Manchmal, ihre Periode,
die Schmerzen, die sie nicht mehr überführen,
gegen diese Periode schmerzen.
Keine allergenen Übertragsigkeiten.
Ihre Mutter und Vater sind gesund.
Bruder, viele psychologische Probleme.
Sie haben auch 5-6 Mal Protakt-Sigaretten
und 3-4 Mal Protakt-Bier trinken.
Können wir so machen,
dass für Sie auch als Planwett,
wie Sie den Patient vorstellen sollen,
Sie machen es gut, aber Sie wiederholen auch
den Menschen, die an der Miese auch immer wieder.
Was ist wichtig ist, wie Sie das am Anfang gestartet haben.
Sie fangen Sie von vornherein,
wir korrigieren ein Einzel-Einzel,
damit Sie auch diese Korrektur als Bild
für die nächste Anamnisierung,
für die nächste Vorstellung bauen.
Anhand der, sollen Sie immer etwas vorstellen.
Dann ist es einfacher.
Ein Start, dass Sie alles schon andere manchmal zählen.
Sollen wir das besser machen,
was machen Sie jetzt?
Ich möchte Sie das mal als Bild machen.
Ich würde das so vorstellen.
Frau Claudia, der Frau Schmidt,
der 40 Jahre alten Patientin,
stellt sich mit einem starker Oberbauchschmerzen.
Die Schmerzen beschreiben Sie als gute Formierung.
Sie haben eine gute Formierung.
Sie haben eine gute Schmerzschmerz.
Sie beschreiben Sie als gute Formierung.
Sie haben eine Ausstrahlung in den Rücken.
So einfach, wie die Schmerzen ist.
Und wie verhält sich.
Und dann weiter zu Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzskala liegt zwischen 7 bis 9.
Sie müssen die Schmerzen gut beschreiben.
Weil Sie am Anfang die Schmerzen beschrieben haben.
Und dann haben Sie die Schmerzskala noch einmal beschrieben.
Da müssen Sie die Schmerzen immer zu Ende bringen.
Von wo fangen die anderen?
Wie stark ist das?
Und was hat sie gegen Schmerzen genommen?
Die hat gestern den Schmerzen nur weil sie ging.
Eingenommen, da hat sie geholfen.
Als Auslußer kann sie nichts genau.
Und dann ist es nicht so,
dass sie nichts genau feststellen oder finden könnten.
Das habe ich auch gefragt.
Wie Sie gesagt haben,
Fieber, Durchfall, wurde verneint.
Aber sie hat seit gestern
unter Obstepationen.
Sie hat seit gestern Obstepationen.
Sie können es auch so sagen.
Und dann weiter jetzt.
Sie haben eine Gewöhnlichkeit.
Jetzt können Sie weiter machen.
Wie viel braucht es?
Dann gehen Sie zum Familienamnese.
Sie sollen den Passivprobleme erst mal bis zu Ende bringen.
Und dann können Sie auf den Familienamnese springen.
Was Probleme hat sie mit seinem Bruder?
Oder was wird das Problem mit seinen Eltern?
Dann können Sie am Ende beschreiben.
Das ist keine Kritik.
Das ist nur für Sie, dass Sie als Konsequizitives
an einem Nese durchführen können.
Wie Sie dann anfangen und wie Sie das beenden.
Ich habe das jetzt gemacht.
Und machen Sie weiter jetzt?
Keine Drogennahme.
Sie sind verarbeitet.
Keine Kinder.
Sie sind Putschfrau von Beruf.
Sie ist Putschfrau von Beruf.
Sie haben ein bisschen Angst.
Was würden Sie jetzt machen?
Sie hat stark Schmerzen.
Was haben Sie hier gegeben?
Für diese Stärken schmerzen.
Danke.
Ich habe das jetzt gemacht.
Spasmonitikum.
Genau.
Sie können auch Spasmonitikum geben.
Sie können nur Walgien geben.
Was vermuten Sie als...
oder was würden Sie noch als Untersuchung durchführen?
Und was vermuten Sie?
Für Blut...
Ich denke, dass es wichtig ist.
Amilas ist ein Sündenbaremitikum.
Er liebt Paz.
Bei Pankretitis liebt Paz wichtig als Amilase.
Bei chronischen Amilases ist auch wichtig.
Aber Paz ist eine gute Pankretitis.
Das ist der wichtige Marker.
Sie nehmen auch Paz.
Die Leberwerte sind auch wichtig.
Die Nierenwerte sind auch wichtig.
Warum?
Wenn Sie eine Pankretitis verdacht haben,
dann kann man eine Sess oder eine Sepsis entwickeln.
Sie brauchen eine große Routine.
Wie Sie gesagt haben, richtig große Blutwelle.
Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Elektrolyte.
Ja.
Warum Elektrolyte?
Weil über Calcemis,
zum Beispiel, ist auch eine Aussage von Pankretitis.
Da soll man auch achten.
Das ist für unsere Elektrolyte auch.
Und weiter, was machen Sie als Nächstes?
Und weiter, können wir Ultroschalbe...
Genau, richtig.
Sie machen einen Ultroschalbe.
Warum? Sie wollen den Organen darstellen.
Überbach Organen.
Darzustellen.
Das heißt, Pankretz zu sehen, genau, wie das aussieht.
Vielleicht Koleidekschutain.
Ja, genau.
Dann können Sie dann andere Ursache auch mal schauen.
Wenn Sie das sehen können, natürlich.
Das ist ein Goldstandarduntersuch, aber muss man machen trotzdem.
Goldstandard ist natürlich das CT durchzuführen.
Aber Sie sind richtig.
Sie haben Ultroschalbe gemacht.
Sie haben etwas gesehen im Pankret.
Das ist Unruhiges, geschwollen.
Was machen Sie als Nächstes?
Nächstes, ich mache CT-Abdomen, ich denke.
Genau, CT-Überbauch.
Sie haben die Banker, wie Sie gesagt haben, den Galenblaser.
Galengänge auch leicht darstellen.
Aber natürlich für die Galengänge braucht man immer CT.
Aber anhand CT sieht man auch schon etwas.
Ja, viele Schneidersteine.
Genau, genau.
Da sehen Sie auch, dass auch gut im CT.
Sehr gut.
Das haben Sie toll gemacht. Sie haben Blutuntersuchungen.
Sie haben CT gemacht.
Sie haben gegen Schmerz und Schmettermittel gegeben.
Das ist auch toll.
Was geben Sie noch als Behandlung?
Sie haben jetzt eine Pankretitis diagnosed.
Die Basis sind auch im CT.
Sie haben eine etriotuxische Pankretitis gesehen.
Das heißt Alkohol bedingt.
Das ist eine gute Pankretitis.
Das ist eine gute Schub.
Sie trägt seit 2-3 Jahren.
Daher hat sie eine Beschwerden.
Was würden Sie noch machen?
Ich denke, ist das nicht aufgenommen?
Das ist nicht aufgenommen.
Die ist aufgenommen.
Diese Labanen haben durchgeführt.
Sie haben CT gemacht.
CT.
Ich denke, ist eine frische Substitution.
Und eine Abteilung von Abteilungen.
Das ist eine gute Phonologie.
Sie wissen nicht genau,
man muss da einen CT gucken.
Sie geben auch Flüssigkeit.
Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt.
In dieser Phase braucht man richtig Flüssigkeit.
Bis 5-6 Liter pro Tag.
Bei Pankretitis und Schmerzmetall.
Bei jeder Bauchschmerzen.
Wenn Sie passieren,
Wenn Sie Patienten eine Notaufnahme haben, Sie müssen eine Schmerztherapie einleiten.
Da gibt es keine Begründung, sie müssen es durchhalten und bis sich den Untersuchung durchgeführt haben.
Sie machen schnell die Diagnostikbauchuntersuchung, Sie müssen das Schmerz lokalisieren, wo das ist, bei Körperuntersuchung.
Und dann, wenn Sie das lokalisiert haben, dann müssen Sie einfach Schmerzmittel geben und sagen,
was sie mit dem Richter, der Links- oder Oberbauchschmerzen kamen, ich habe es geguckt,
da hat keiner Rebound, der hat keine andere Symptome, die auch relevant ist oder war.
Und dann können Sie Schmerzmittel geben, weil dann haben Sie das so erfasst in Schmerzen, wie das war und wie das wird.
Daher dieser Idee, dass man die Leute, die mit dem Bauchschmerzeln kommen,
so lange man die Diagnose nicht hat, gar nichts zu geben, ist falsch.
Haben Sie verstanden?
Ja.
Oder soll ich das langsam wiederholen?
Können Sie wiederholen, Fragen?
Hab ich gesagt, das ist keine Frage, das ist nur einfach.
Wenn Sie eine Patientin haben in der Notaufnahme, der oder die, die sich mit dem Bauchschmerzen vorstellt,
die sollen nach Körperuntersuchung, nach Schmerzlokalisation und Schmerz an einem Näsar sofort ein Schmerzmittel geben.
Okay? Der oder die Patientin soll nicht unter Schmerzen leiden.
Das heißt, sie müssen schmerzfrei werden.
Das ist das Ziel in der Notaufnahme.
Wir müssen nicht Patienten mit dem Schmerz hin und her schieben,
damit man die Diagnose gesichert hat.
Anders schulde ich mal.